we are live streaming
we are and uh commence the meeting thank
you for a great
turnout and welcome
so
my running instructions here
um uh
just like to um recognize
whether we have anybody on zoom or we're
all here
bobby it's great to see you normally
it's being by zoom this community
you're with us and i hope as well
um so right we're into it so do we have
any apologies
people stay the course of the meeting um
it's set through 11 but we're
recognizing we'll probably
go over just a tear i'm although i've
been told we must finish by 12. um so
that's fine
um are there any matters are there any
matters in front of us that
you have concerns about your interests
being none i haven't been informed of
public or
anybody watching to speak at the public
forum
change and order now i must confess i
haven't quite caught up with this
agenda item 8 which is our annual report
update
um is to be moved up until i think uh
straight after the minutes because we
have derrick our auditor with the stare
of olsen
um so we will we will deal with that
very quickly after we've dealt with the
minutes
um and indeed not acknowledging that
derek is there derek can you hear us by
the way
oh okay
right here notice just so that we he can
be ready to go and i think jenna
probably is also drawing
those are the only agenda items i have
uh sorry changes i have to the agenda
nobody
i don't think there's anything else that
we
need to
note at this stage
right let's just while we're getting
derek
admitted to the room can we just look at
the first item which is the minutes from
last meeting
i'll move from the chair that they're
accepted as a true and correct record
over secondary please
thank you any matters of accuracy or
comment people need to recognize
um just being slightly picky here can we
just get the numbers right please on uh
it was a page 13 where we try and take
is it 50 million uh to get it derive our
net debt number
87 million dollars less 50 giving us 38
million dollars in net debt
that's 37 should be the number um that's
on page 13 malavika of the
um the agenda
and one always looks at what one says or
if reported to have said
um and i just noticed the the importance
to approve the draft annual report in
september
can we say uh at the end of that an
effective recommendations
consistent with a letter of
representation please rather than
made through a letter
brilliant
uh
anything oh and um
there are a couple of actions i'll
follow up on but if if nobody else has
got any comments on it i will put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
those against
gary good
right can i just check a couple of
action items um one of them was that uh
actually under that item on page
815 uh ross and i were charged with um
working with uh krishna team and with
derek and his team on a monthly basis to
to
seek a collaborative approach to getting
to our
board of work we are doing that
um ross in particular apology was it
last friday
i think
ross so that's going which is fine
clear there was one thing i noted on the
action item which was you and me
on page 16 which recommends that we
write to order new zealand and advise
them
that it is the council's intention
to
do we need to do that or we've resolved
it but i'm wondering whether we need to
do it i'm sure that we can advance
i think we can do that okay good that's
just the outside
so look what's that can we then move on
please having brought forward item eight
uh which is the
2022 annual report
and there at this time check that we've
got you online and can hear you
good morning
morning
derrick
great to see you there that's superb so
we can move toward a mate please um
which is indeed the
uh the the annual audit um patricia is
anything that you want to say
introducing this will we cut across
today
um we'll just i'll just take it as read
and i think we cut across to derrick
because the the critical part is the
audit plan from audit new zealand for
um this audit and then i can tie up any
of the administration things from our
side at the end yes we'll circle back
particularly to the dates which i think
is probably critical from the
perspective of where we're at at the
moment okay derek welcome to the meeting
thank you for being available this
morning
um uh look can you give us a heads up
please on your plan
thank you bruce thank you patricia and
uh good morning committee members
um yes um i'm thankful for the
opportunity then also to present our
order plan for this year's uh audit
um i'll just highlight some key
uh areas from this oracle as i also do
take it as being read i probably just
want to highlight some of the key risks
that we've
outlined
in terms of what our focus areas will be
we've had engagements with management
and we believe these are the key areas
to focus on for this year's audit first
is probably the revaluation of
property plant and equipment
this was an area that i think had a lot
of attention last year and again this
year
management has decided and council had
decided to revalue all
um assets or property platinum equipment
so again this will be a big focus for
our audit
this year
ensuring
that the
carrying value of assets do represent
the fair market value
again we'll have
quite a few discussions with the
respective valuers
ensuring we get a full understanding of
market conditions so that
the carrying value do represent
fair value
also what we've identified
around investment property we've
increased our scope this year
around investment property last week we
only looked at
the fair value
and valuation of investment properties
where this year
we'll be doing a more fulsome
approach around investment properties
looking at the
full um cycle of of investment
properties also selecting some of
sales of investment properties during
the year we look at the operational
effectiveness of how
investment properties are brought into
account
so there is quite a um
increasing the scope around investment
properties
also just software as a service this is
something new that's that's also coming
into effect where
um
council will probably be engaging
um and
entering into significant cloud
computing arrangements
uh in the near future
so we'll also just be looking at that
and ensuring that
that is dealt with appropriately from an
accounting and financial reporting
perspective
so those are maybe the three areas from
a
risk perspective that i wanted to
highlight
also just
maybe to note
we have included some additional focus
areas those are focused areas that
normally comes through from
a sepa
perspective
so these are areas that we'll be looking
at
for all councils across the country and
they're also included in the order
generals ordered briefs so there's an
expectation from the auditor general
also that we
look at those
respective areas
across the sector
also i've highlighted in the audit plan
um from a group perspective what are the
areas we'll be focusing on
when one looks at the group
um icl rchl being um the only
significant group
for council
ichl and group does have
its own subsidiaries
and those all feed into
into council's financials through the
group accounting
so we are engaging with the appointed
auditor on those
uh respective
entities also to get a full
understanding of the impacts that this
will have on
group reporting
also maybe just started to do including
our order plan our materiality threshold
uh for this year we've set it again at
uh from a council perspective at 60
million
with a specific materiality at 2.35
million
and then maybe just the another thing
that i want to highlight is maybe just
around the timing of the audit
as you are aware last year parliament
granted
an extension to reporting deadlines for
various
sectors and entities
whereby councils had
their deadline extend up until the
31st of december
that was for a two-year period
we will still be utilizing the full
extent of that
extension that was granted last year
um seeing that we are still building
capacity and the establish or the
shortage
um within the
auditing profession and current
environment
as a result of covet
and covert against might still impact
us during the audit process as we as
we've seen
during the start of this year um in some
of our other clients
whereby there has been
impacts due to stopping off and needing
to isolate and then various
aspects uh emanating from coven
um so we will be utilizing the full
extent of that extension
and in terms of the proposed timing um
to issue our audit opinion on the 20th
of december
so to be with with that i'll pause there
for any questions thanks dear appreciate
that um first community members uh great
to have derek here is there any
questions you'd like to raise with derek
yes
um
it's about the asset valuation obviously
um i
just want to get this straight that
because of the marketplace um costs we
have to revalue our assets to make them
align is that right
because it's it's
more expensive to do stuff is that right
um
actually counselor this is the year that
we would have been revaluing all our
assets
yeah not withstanding there had been a
significant do we revalue them to
current marketplace you know right
okay so that leads me to the next
question then you can
liken this to say domestic property
now the the average homeowner's house
would go up in price if building costs
go up because it makes sense okay
building costs drop
per square meter then obviously the
value of existing houses would
would level out accordingly i'm saying
so come a recession or anything do we
and the cost of doing business becomes
cheaper
do we then revalue accordingly
to the reduced market
yes the answer is
let's just spec the truck up
okay
what we are doing is
council has adopted and is required to
adopt the concept of fair value
okay which is which is essentially the
market is essentially a market valuation
yep
the point is that most of our assets the
large asset base that we have you can't
do on a market basis
okay so a market basis with your house
or domestic house
would be essentially by reference to
what recent sales
so it's you don't value
what i was trying to do
you don't value your house
based based on the cost to build it's
the market value if you're doing fair
value probably about analogy there but
probably a bad analogy there well that's
the energy you gave so the critical the
critical thing around
our specialized assets is the use of
what we call depreciated replacement
cost which gets you exactly back to that
point
um so so
theoretically you're correct
if contract rates went down
arguably
there might be
some form of devaluation of the
that's what i'm asking but but
i'd like to say over the last 20 years
that hasn't happened
right
okay i've just noticed that um
in our writing contracts and stuff for
example we've we've a lot of the
contracts have come and way under budget
because
they've told us it's the nature of the
business at the moment there's not much
happening and stuff like that so
i guess roads are an asset and
that's an example you know of a fall in
the market
and i just wonder if there is a fall in
the market do we re-evaluate but
obviously not uh um
um well you would take things into
account so so there are two things that
we we have had to do and you'll recall
with with derek last year we had some
challenges which was around doing a fair
value assessment so what what you are
doing if you are not going to re-value
which was not last year
we do what is called a fair value
assessment to make certain that in your
non-revaluation year you shouldn't be
revaluing or recognizing some form of
market adjustment
there was nothing
so that's when you would consider
potentially those change in those
contract or market rates but i suspect
they're not going to go down
right right
no that's
answer that clearly thank you
um and look it's important that we you
know it is it's a difficult um
uh area particularly given that i think
with three waters reforms it's something
that we need to have on a reasonably
accurate basis so i do look forward to
the fact that we've got to do ourselves
and get it right are there other
questions thank you for that right i
think snotty yeah just for derek
directly um
given the performance last year of audit
new zealand and given your
um i guess um inability to recruit
enough auditors which seems to be across
the board and the impacts of covert
which haven't gone away
just wonder about the mindset of adding
additional focuses that you've listed
here three waters prudent expenditure
setting of rates and integrity and
ethics
um
are you comfortable that you can deliver
all that which is i guess is extra work
given that last year we struggled a bit
with time frames
yes
those are
um sector specific requirements coming
through from the
office of the auditor general directly
okay um so those those need to be
performed um i think regardless
there has been some cutback on other
areas that we haven't included in the
plan specifically um taking that into
account
thank you
good thank you yes ross i
also support the the
monthly meetings we're holding focus
around about four key areas one is
timeliness one's resources
uh technical issues both accounting and
others so
we're making sure there are no surprises
and on both sides there are resources
and yeah privacy so we're well aware and
can plan yeah so
that's the assurance i'll give the
committee that it's getting monitored
yeah more often than just every rna
update yeah that's cool thank you the
the the joint objective navi is to get
to the 15th of december i should
actually be on the dates
december happy is the that's the word
we're using which means
all these things are wrinkled out so um
that'll be the challenge but thank you
it's a good point navi there's a lot
there is a lot that derek has to do to
complete his engagement so
it's a fair point any other questions
for there
let us ask couple please derek um
probably it isn't one of those um areas
of of extra stuff i noted um the prudent
expenditure decisions
um i'd love us to be proved prudent
um
how do you go about that
because it's more than sensitive
expenditure what can i can you give this
indication for the benefit of the
committee what you're doing
in the area of prudent
expenditure decisions this is uh on
what page it is of yours it's it's page
six of your report of your report of 63
of our agendas
yeah so gee i think in this area it's a
lot to do with uh the processes
and procedures that council have in
place
to ensure that they've got um
appropriate decision making
mechanisms in place for any decision
that gets made
so it will be a lot of discussion with
management
besides as you've highlighted you know
the area of sensitive expenditure where
we select specific transactions
also we do um
select transactions
on a random basis to ensure that there's
a level of unpredictability
so that
any transaction that we do
scrutinize or select and look at we will
have that prudent expenditure lens when
we look at that specific transaction or
item that we've selected
brilliant that'll be good to see the
results of it um specifically so that's
great hey um just on the group stuff
thank you for including the group um
concerns it was with quite some detail
and the plan that's really helpful derek
i presume you and chris uh particularly
where you're dealing with extern with
other parties that are undertaking the
audits that you are
um in early conversation with them about
what are your
con risk risk assessments with each of
those
uh initial assessments with each of
those subsidiaries
yes gee so similarly as what i do
by sending as group instructions to
chris
for my expectations of as the group
auditor similarly you will send out
group instructions to each of the
respective entities that he audits
within the group
and uh and i understand those have
already gone out to their respective
entities so what if i could just get the
committee to go back to page 55 of the
agenda and patricia probably keyed this
round back here on the uh the timeline
um which is quite extensive but it also
is reflecting you're right i don't know
why i had 15th of december in my head uh
20th of december is the date to actually
adopt the annual report would be a great
christmas present
there
um anything here that you need to raise
with us at this
please patricia no at this stage
everything is on plan so the team the
audit team were actually down here in
invercargill last week
and have completed the field work for
the interim audit um so we're just
waiting for that will be reported back
at the next risk insurance meeting
and um
on that the only thing that will
potentially be at risk is asset
revaluations because we are not the only
ones trying to revalue our assets at
this stage
so that is the uh
that is the problem in the market at the
moment so it's actually finding a value
or is that correct uh we've got valuers
yeah that's getting them to come and do
it
okay
at the moment we should be all on time
but
yes i can understand that had been an
issue
so members the 27th of september is a
big date for us um
it's the last meeting we will have in
this training
and
we are trying to lay the foundation to
be able to pass over to the new council
constituted after the eighth obviously
some assurance
so they can do the work on the 20th in
terms of adopting the annual report so
it'll be
based around the general principle that
we will want to
understand and confirm the draft annual
report that's at a group level so that
includes also the subsidiaries
and indeed our non-financial information
informal view on those
and the second part is that
we will consider what are the
representations that the new council
will be required to make to derek
because i think it'll be important for
us particularly to pass on to the new
council
what our views are so that seems like
have we maintained our systems of
control through the year has there been
an absence of fraud um we are a going
concern standard things that go with a
lot of representation so that's that
will become the agenda on the 27th and a
key date um uh note that derek still has
a lot of work to do there but i'll
clearly be obviously keen that derek is
there with us in that process as well
we're not signing off the accounts we
can't but we need to leave the best
foundation we can for the council going
forward
thank you for that if there's another
questions can i move to the
recommendations please
um which is we receive the report
we note the detailed uh plan um
we know that there is ongoing
communication thank you ross for your
quick update on that and the valuations
of operational structural asset
investment
investment property and forestry
they've commenced
as in we know where they are is okay and
the work has started oh the work has
started so that's good
um thank you
very appreciate that and give a second
to please
thank you x
uh any discussion on the motion i'll put
it all those in favor please say aye
those against
it's carrie thank you very much thank
you derek appreciate that and
look forward to to the issues being
resolved as quickly as we can in your
participation thank you mate appreciate
that thank you bruce thank you committee
members enjoy the rest of your day
right we can move back to
our
agenda as it was standing so we've done
automated we're back to item five which
is a health and safe health and safety
risk update please
have to take it as read is there any
questions that people want to raise with
these
have the reports received
you moved oh thank you rangi
that's question yeah oh you want a
question please go for it are my
questions around the effectiveness of
the
due diligence
site visits
you know coming from a contracting
environment
um i see them as is quite superficial
and uh
and going through you know not not an
effective thing you know they might they
might be ticking in the central box
but you know to me they're
yeah yeah they are they aren't really
from what i've seen in the in the in the
actual contracting world
more than a box ticker and
you know do we is that is that enough or
okay
um
oh sorry it actually clear actually i
think put a well i was indicating to
michael oh sorry oh i'm happy to speak
oh okay right sorry
so who's speaking too sorry there's a
new model
through yourself chair you're happy to
take that one on uh look site visits are
being reviewed but from uh
executive point of view we are
reviewing how we undertake the site
visits at the moment as well uh just to
make sure we're getting the full value
out of that from an organization and
making sure we're we're
ensuring the compliance requirements are
met but also getting a fuller health and
safety
exposure into those
site visits as well so we're undertaking
like i say a review of our own approach
uh from an executive level
um but we will be looking at that from
how we do that with the governance level
at the same time
we wholeheartedly agree with the
responsibility in relation to those site
visits and our requirements under the uh
with the contractors
um i'd like to just suggest that this is
on the biggs the old borough premise
wellington city are just looking at
actually what should it particularly
from a government's perspective a
councillor be doing on a site visit it's
more than just going and saying g'day to
somebody that's working on the site so
there may well be your points well made
running that actually
if we're going to go on site visits it
should be with an effective and good
good uh approach
to understanding what's going on so i
don't know where one can are on that but
out of the last health workshop that was
definitely a must do so michael that may
be something to i can give you the
context there to see whether they've
taken that forward
darren sorry i think you had to do uh
thanks my comment was simply going to be
that surely the majority of that
responsibility rests on the shoulders of
the elected members to know
what they need to be asking
uh look i agree and and i think what i'm
just reflecting on my wellington
experience here there and was actually
it's been looked at by others as to what
we do as as as governors so let's let's
use what they might have if they've got
it we've got to no no i actually dispute
that there's a problem here because you
walk onto a site and
if you ask if a governance person asks
specific questions on ppe
on on the use of machinery and stuff
like this they're crossing the line into
a management thing
and and that's what i'm
that's what i'm getting at is is that
you could go on site and do drill right
down but that's not our position i want
to know the interface between governance
and management on how this works
yeah
look i think i think
we need to recognize
our obligations under section 44 of the
act
so we need we need to and i think this
is the point i'm saying um without
getting the detail ringing i'd be um
being boring staring off wellington for
instance
that that this has got to come from the
perspective of a governor
but the obligation is to verify
now verify is a small word but it could
have a big meaning and i think this is
the value of where of where it's going i
i hear your point
that that actually governance
you know should stay out of the fire but
actually the relative it is this has got
a specific obligation to verify
um and so to understand better what a
counselor should do on a site visit
is important for two reasons one it
makes it proper and valuable but it also
probably also
helps protect the position you're in
or you're arguing which is actually
how detailed should they go
our obligations to understand systems
and processes and so i would be coming
from a governance lens on that base if i
was on a visit can i say rangi i think
for the sake of the meeting it's well
we've got a suggestion here this needs
to be looked at michael i think you've
suggested that's the case can we task
michael just to
eventually come back to us with what is
the appropriate approach a governor
should take when they walk on site
running so what i was trying to
establish are we happy with what we've
currently got or do we are we seeking to
do it better
chair i think we're always seeking to do
things better so i think that's an
answer that is in the affirmative for
everything i think so yes mommy um agree
with rangy i think we're very
lightweight in the area of health and
safety it's two ad hoc
i've got 10 years experience as a
government inspector in this area
and when you rely on committees and
workplaces to
analyse themselves or to look for
incidents that might lead you to
something a bit more serious
or you crisscross over and cross
pollinate where somebody from one
committee goes and looks at another
person's ear
it's limited by the experience of the
person to see what other people don't
see
and so i think we've we've got a
risk in that area i've raised it before
uh we don't have a designated health and
safety
manager as such that would bring that
sort of expertise
um
i've investigated many accidents where
people internally just get used to doing
things the wrong way
and so i think we've got a risk here i
personally even with my background would
not be wandering around council
facilities
and into gauging as ranging you said i
think that's the wrong approach to take
we just need assurances of the things
that are actually occurring
and getting quality in that area and i
think it's a an area to grow into
yes thank you greg
thanks jeff
just a very quick note that i happen to
be president of the inspection on the
steed street stock bank
evaluation um
rather unbeknown to me i got co-opted
into it on the time of the inspection
but i was impressed
it wasn't just an ad hoc
look at that look at that there was a
detailed
sheet as selection of sheets and answers
and questions to to be looked at it
wasn't just
as a wing of a prayer because on the day
it was all pre-planned with extensive
documentation
thanks for that insight great
any other comment on this
so look i think i think um just a couple
of things what one is um i note under
under public excluded we we have got a
very good
development of a risk framework a
tsunami i think that's actually a good
place to discuss
what are the nature of our strategic
risks including
your concern and would be mine as well
around health safety and wellbeing
and actually what is our approach i
think equally we've also agreed in
effect to ask michael around the issue
of of making certain the sort of
approach that you've outlined graham
is one which is the most effective and
is the right one that a governor should
take so um
i think that's if we can hold that
together that would be a very effective
way to start ramping up or being
affirmed assured about our approach
around health and safety as governors
that would be great any other comments
folk would like to make
right um
that being the case can we move to the
resolutions please
um and it is simply that we
receive the update
i'll move that from the cheer do i have
a second to please
thank you ross appreciate that
discussion on the motion
i'll put it all those in favor please
say aye
those against
it's carrie
right we can move to um the uh also
you're about to skip skip over working
on working together item six please
yeah in fact my favorite topic is it
[Laughter]
so
again michael is anything that you want
to write probably would be useful to
hear your heads up please given this is
a new task that has been given us as you
will recall from uh the council
decisions in whatever may was it um and
michael it would be useful to see get
that heads up from you as to where to
from here please
everybody
um
thank you mr chair
so yes this is the uh
first
and final report on the working working
together a work stream coming through to
this committee this committee has
provided the oversight of
the working on working together group
and council has resolved that the
remaining risks
be transferred to the council risk
register and that has been completed as
you can see in the report
so that there is ongoing
monitoring of those
risks
this includes
the internal audit of
the reporting templates
uh
of staff reports coming through
this one i've picked on because i know
that that work is underway within your
internal auditor
working that up so she's got her work
program to
commence with that
um
i think just working through the notes
jane has given me to speak to
and i think
i have covered everything
there
yes you just wanted to note something as
i've said but it's probably worth um
repeating that with the legacy report
being completed in the response received
from their department
the work of ptg and the external
appointees has concluded responsibility
for monitoring for solely on this
committee at this
time so it was just something jane
wanted me to emphasise and with that i'm
otherwise happy to answer any questions
to ensure the meeting continues to move
forward so like i will be interested i
really just said sort of how two
questions or what what what are the next
steps here from michael and one is how
will we monitor those risks and i think
we can pick it up
this later that when we we talk about
our
risk framework
i am interested though in the outcomes
um because uh that was an important
document to the whole program
that we are we are seeking outcomes here
and that that is still open
are you the guardian of the outstanding
steps as far as the monitoring framework
is concerned
i will place myself as the overarching
guardian i may not be watching
specific outcome but i will be the
person who will present
those through to this committee uh as
required to make and to ensure that the
team behind me uh all work together to
make sure that these come before this
committee when required
brilliant look that's good because i'm
just conscious that actually they're
monitoring framework there's a lot of
action that should really happen post 30
june um and so
that's that's great to know um because i
am very keen that we
we uh we keep this up thank you for that
uh that explanation committee members
only any questions people would like to
raise at this stage
yes michael oh sorry tim yes
thank you mr chair um
i thought that this had been resolved as
an issue so tim could you just be we
were close to the microphone i'll pull
it closer to you please
i thought this had been resolved in the
public domain anyway where it um
the
issues seem to be
either downplayed or
the outcome was not what was expected
and
i think it would be better just to
leave it alone for a while
so tim i think it would be fair to say
from my recollection of the council
meeting that um that that
preceded this and hence the paper that
we've got
um
uh um
recognize that the majority of the work
had been done
we spent 80 months with jeff and lindsay
doing doing the hard yards in the way
that you've said
we agreed also
that actually it was time for the actual
program itself
to conclude
um particularly
in that importance for for us
not to have the training wheels of jeff
and lindsay with us
but that the
objectives
of the program and the risks were still
real
and that the risk committee should
monitor those which is exactly which is
exactly what michael is encouraging us
and jane is encouraging us to do through
this process so
um
i don't believe
uh in terms of the
work that's been done for the last two
years that it's now just dropped and
forgotten we need to make certain that
the gains are still maintained
the risks are that we lose them and we
slip back into ways that gave rise to
the original
letter from the department
so we we're still in the program if you
will
but it's on a different basis it's
self-managing
are there any other questions people
like rangi
my question is around the resident
survey and
reading it it
it sounds like they're going to use the
2022 which is this year as the baseline
against another survey so that makes me
believe that we haven't had previous
resident surveys is that correct i'd
have to refer to mike we have had
previous resident surveys i don't
believe we've had this specific question
relating to the the governance aspect
asked before so this is essentially that
baseline in that resident survey for
that specific question okay the reason
i'm asking is that okay it shows a low
very low
view of this council but
it'd be interesting to know what it
dropped from
uh previously that obviously we haven't
done that so
there is no baseline
and it is possible that we are
consistent with previous views
potentially
it's potentially absolutely correct
counselor um
or it also could be that we've now got a
baseline right
and
it's now for this knowledge
exactly
i think this is the key the key thing
look you know we all know that we're
coming up to elections we all know that
there's a sense to which we want trust
and confidence in the community
the resident survey is is
part of that process of us trying to
assess these outcomes
um so like i accept the fact that
there would have been surveys in the
past this particular question hasn't
been asked before
um but that doesn't mean to say we
shouldn't be trying to do it oh no go
forward but it's it's it's you've got to
place it in perspective yes
yeah i like i agreed um i think what was
also going to reflect rangi sorry i
realized that it had another point
because of course this is the key
challenge that the department has left
us with
how do we build build the trust and
confidence given
the results of the the interim surveys
that we've done today
is still saying there's work to do here
thank you nobby and two just two things
um randy's quite right the previous ones
we've done and the more current ones
we've done we've changed the format of
how we connect
in the surveys
and um
yeah
one is at the expense the other one
format
is very negative when people have an
online thing they just get in and bag
off council if you speak to them on the
phone you can actually tease through
some of the issues and and get a better
result so we're not really at this stage
in the position it could be apples with
apples a little bit different
the other thing is the wider issue if
they're working for working together um
just the comments that uh certain made
and as chair of that group we have got
to sort of the end of the
into the activity with that we still
have a couple of areas to work on the
supporting the mayor one uh still had
some unresolved issues and that they're
well documented and i think in the area
of the uh
media going forward that uh claire and
lisa have done some work not too long
ago in the workshop to look at
strategically where we go with their
their whole media function so
the areas are still work in progress i
guess thank you i agree
which reflects the point that actually
there's more still to be done which is
correct any other comments people like
to make at the stage
number like to move to the
move to the uh uh the
motion knowing that risks get picked up
through our normal risk function which
we'll have a discussion on later in the
meeting uh and michael uh the
overarching guardian of helping us keep
on the straight narrow with monitoring
uh the outcomes which should still be
something that we take seriously and
thank you that you have this morning
talking about this ever
uh so do i have a movement signal that
we received the report please thank you
ross do i have a second day thank you
i'll put the motion in please all those
in favor please say aye
those against
it's carrick thank you
all right can we move to
item seven which uh the financial risk
update thank you michael appreciate that
appreciate your rights
so our councillors this is the um report
for the march quarter so from the period
from 1 january through the 31 march um
in terms of a net debt position
council has 88.3 million of outstanding
debt
45.4 million of cash and cash
investments
which are
million net debt position which is
slightly higher than the last quarter
um we continue to have that minor breach
in our treasury policy around fixed
interest in the
two to four year category which we're
continuing to monitor but at the moment
fixing interest rates at that point
forward would not necessarily
be advised and that's um shown in the
treasury report given the volatility of
interest rates at the moment
and we'll continue to monitor that
that
percentage is still based on our
projected capital program going forward
so any reductions or increases in our
capital project program affect that
um we are seeing some increases in
interest rates and that's um splits
shown in the report where um after the
end of march we have renewed one of our
long-term debt
amounts and it was significantly higher
we're at the four percent over the four
percent mark where most of our debt
currently is held at one or two percent
so there's a significant shift there
in terms of our debt
um that we're continuing to monitor that
there's a significant move from the
quarter
from the december one mainly because
mb's paid us for stead street
so that continues to be an ongoing
control but there's not
that much more left on that project and
we are getting a lot of movement on our
rates arrears um
there's a new um
at this time of the year is when we send
in any of those with more arrears with
mortgages to our lawyers to have the
mortgages the mortgage the mortgage ores
collect
the rates on our behalf
and we're seeing that number drop down
significantly
thank you for that darren i think this
paper that comes to us from a risk
perspective but it comes through your
committee is anything you want to add to
this at the stage no nothing further to
worry about patricia said are there any
other questions folk would like to raise
on the report yes
three things um do the easiest one first
uh patricia you mentioned that
changes to capex expenditure going
forward and long-term plan could
influence the net debt situation
fair to say that um
if for some reason we reduce our
um go forward expenditure and capex it
would have a positive effect as opposed
to negative yes yep thank you the other
issue is the when i look back three
months ago the last report that we got
which is 24 march
um
we've got the movement between the cash
and cash investments from 50 down to now
down to 45
so two questions in relation to that
one is what was the money spent on
um and the other issue is it seems like
and this might answer the first question
it seems like that we're now holding
some other investments
and you've got them listed there as
share investments advances of loans to
icl
and loan advantages to other so they
total up to about six million dollars
and in the past i haven't seen that so
when we're looking at net data we're now
including more than just cash and cash
and
equivalents and we are now including
loans that we might have out to other
entities
answer the second part first and you
might have to remind me what the first
question first question was counselor um
the loans and advances is the line that
council agreed to provide to
invercargill um central limited so
that's a short term loan so we can
include that in our cash okay um in cash
investments and i think the share
investments and the loans and advances
to others have always been there but
probes haven't been as large yeah that's
okay that answers first question can you
remind me no no that answers the first
question because that's where the
movement is
yeah thank you
right any other questions thank you for
that nobby
right i just had um
that's very useful um it does reflect uh
going back to your question obviously
the cost doing business is increasing
and we see that through the funding
arrangements that cost us more to have
in place
so i take the point that if we don't do
the capex it actually
has a perverse impact on helping us
retain retain costs but it does
have an impact on levels of service
well that's what we think about that
that's what i was alluding to because i
mean rangi raised at one of our recent
meetings you know what would happen if
we
delayed or actually cancelled the
project exactly um does that improve our
financial position as far as that net
yeah
and it would do it needs to include both
parts of the discussion sure so i think
take your point on that can i just ask
one minor question please i note that
we're moving um we will be moving
towards our insurance reveal
and it just made me think of
two things one i presume
public liability is challenged in terms
of costs that'll be a cost that will go
up
the second one is
uh will the revaluation of the of our
underground assets change our insurance
uh and thirdly do we and are we trying
to get cyber security insurance which is
you foreign we've already got cyber
security insurance okay so we have that
um we are waiting for our brokers at the
moment on our public liability um and
insurance they are saying the market is
challenged um that was their update from
last week so um that's not what i was
wanting to hear but
and
the revaluation of all our buildings and
their underground uh underground
infrastructure is also being revalued
for insurance purposes and that will
affect
that
yeah thank you i
probably i knew what the answer was
again i'm just wanting to reflect from a
financial risk perspective um
that around the sector the issue or even
insurances is starting to impact on the
cost
of doing business so thank you for that
appreciate that patricia right that's
that's um that's wonderful
wonderful that's great there are no
other questions i don't censor any oh
there
yeah just a small one on financial risks
and it's going to come up later on today
and in our fees and everything but
the dog registrations being over 106 000
you know and that equates to
you know over well over a thousand
animals you know it's it's
it just doesn't seem right that it would
get out to that
you know it's just
you know it's it's amazing that uh you'd
imagine a small percentage but that to
me is quite massive
and how does how does it get like that
do we
you're talking about the outstanding
debt yeah the outstanding debt it's it's
quite unreal
so we have experienced high turnover of
staff and that animal control team
over the past year and the team are
working with those outstanding customers
that have not paid their debt they've
worked with them over that time period
but we have
anecdotally noticed a number of
people are finding it harder to pay for
registrations and we work with them
on options that are available some of
those include they sometimes don't want
to have a pet anymore
right just given the registration for
our uh d6 dog 65
now you know the the amount you spend on
food for a dog is is significantly way
more than that
and it's just part and parcel of earning
a dog but the question i've got is
say that lapses to the next year is that
debt carried forward for the unpaid bill
and so you you accumulate or is that
white
no it
it
accumulates
right
thank you rangi i think um for the sake
of time i yeah i hear your point um and
it'll just reflect um perhaps one of the
tougher of those deep balances that i've
seen yet there
in the nature of its quality
right can i move to the recommendations
it's a big one
so i don't propose
to read it to read it out
other than to
reflect it is a it is comprehensive in
terms of indicating the nature
of the um
uh the risks that we have and the
changes that have occurred
so for the ease of that i'll move from
the chair that uh um that all these
motions have taken this one and that we
um we resolved to take them over a
second please
i'm seeing those thank you vex there's
any discussion on the motion
being none i'll put all those in favor
please say aye
those against it's carrie thank you very
much
right could we uh then move to um
the annual report that's great isn't it
so we'd have the quarterly performance
update please
how are you lovely to catch up with you
highlights please
um
i'll take the report
as read um it outlines what the
performance issues are that council is
um experiencing many of them in the area
of um coved it just highlights that this
is a fast-moving changing environment
and we're looking at those trends and
see which ones
will rebound back
and it does highlight the focus on
performance as part of the wider
long-term planning process happy to take
any questions
thank you ryan appreciate that
very clear report poker the questions
for
other community members would like to
ask about the report
right i have a couple oh sorry oh sorry
nobody yeah just on
page 84 of board books and page three of
the report itself it says
forecast year in budget
the forecast deficit will not be
impacted by council's
ability to make payments
and talks about subsidies and debt as
well
not too long ago probably within the
last fortnight or so we've we've had
advice from the finance team that
actually we were heading to a surplus
this year not a deficit so that
those two statements don't sort of run
together i just wanted some
clarification on that
um i'll pass that question to the
finance manager yeah good on you michael
yeah
i think this comes back to the operating
deficit councillor
um
that we've got a forecast operating
deficit because of
the nature of our capital subsidies
coming in so that is a the mitigation is
the subsidies will not will put us in a
cash positive position
just some clarification on it through
your chair
um
previous statement also from the finance
team said that um
that the income that we were receiving
in this financial year from the um
government subsidies
was also being expanded this year as
well
so does that does that lead us to the
position that
we've we've
got some subsidy money that outweighs
what we've actually expended and that
gives us some ability at the towards the
end of the year and to
make payments as a quote say
i wonder uh
i don't want to um what's the word nobby
um
stop good questioning and i don't have
trouble with you asking the question
i understand that we have a short
workshop at the end of this where we
would want to go through this in more
detail okay just fine to explain
quite frankly the difference we have
between accrual accounting
and the particular challenge we have
which is that we have capital subsidy
flowing through our profit and loss
account which is accrual but we don't
have the expenditure
and so we have this distinction between
an operating deficit
which is our day-to-day living versus
versus our capital um but i think it
would be good to have some
uh
i'm going to say a diagram uh in front
of us
and that's going to come but michael
you're probably going to solve
everything for me in one
quick sentence
through yourself chair no sorry i won't
be solving everything um but just given
the workshop um
we'll be following this i just thought
from uh to answer the question from a
public point of view uh just to clarify
that the expenditure is capital in
nature and sits in the balance sheet
side of it
um just so when
council will be looking at it how that
impacts from that perspective but just
so the public aware that is why with an
opera operating surplus it does not sit
in the
operating performance measures it sits
over in your balance sheet and the
capital side when you spend that
expenditure that's the two but we will
work through that with council uh post
meeting
we are we are at some of the challenging
end um nobody here of of
um being in conventional accrual
accounting
versus the challenges of actually as
we're discussing here the operating
versus the capital budgets that we run
essentially separately
yes darren
next year i just wonder if there is a
degree of
what counselor clark is asking about the
reporting difference coming from the
fact that we were updated
during may and this is a reporting
period that ends at the end of march
good point
that's a reasonable comment i think
darren actually there are there are
probably some challenges with timing of
reports getting getting to this
committee versus what you're doing on a
current basis particularly around the
annual plan i presume correct yeah okay
so we will have that workshop which will
hopefully try and shed a little bit of
light as the what us accountants do
nobby yep
you'll be dazzled by what we do i can
assure you
right any other questions folk would
like to raise let's joke
i'd like to uh um uh
any other questions this is the time
that i just look i do ask
ariana and patricia
um capex at 51.9 million versus i think
probably what we intend around 73
million dollars we're at 71
um we've had a discussion the previous
paper that does have some benefits from
from a debt and and cost perspective but
it is the level of service
perspective
so we're going to be presumably
deferring
uh capital programs we'll roll them over
the infamous carry forwards into the new
year
etc
is this all manageable
are our levels of service being
maintained can somebody help me with
that i don't know whether you can run it
or have you got a good pass
um
there are specific issues within the
capital program i think that levels of
service are broadly being maintained but
i will patricia will have more specifics
on the dollars
it might be michael actually so there we
go that's where i got it at the second
five now
thank you through yourself chair with my
other hat on at the moment looking after
the pmo side of it
uh look our delivery obviously is a
little bit behind in relation to that
schedule as you see with the financial
numbers there
we are on track with most of our
strategic projects and that'll be
highlighted in pmo report later in the
agenda
there are some challenges we have with
our renewals program with delivery
supply chain etc that's highlighted here
in relation to those that expenditure
and answer to your
point around does that carry over into
next year
in the renewals program not so much
we only have so much that we can do
within a year so we don't carry a lot of
that uh work through we um
the physical work needs to carry through
but the actual dollars we can't increase
our scope in there
but
from perspective of our strategic
projects we're pretty much on track
there's a little bit of a delay but not
a lot
so we are continuing to go through that
um i would say
most of it is in the renewal space and
we are working on that as
for delivery for next year right that's
something which from a risk perspective
i stress i will be just to understand
how we go because i gained the sense
from reading the papers that it's the
renewal program that is behind
um and and it's the stored up
like deferred maintenance that we can
build into our underground and our
generally underground systems which
worry me so
um dare i start even with due diligence
coming up or upon us over three waters i
think that would be interesting point if
i was looking at us i'd be keen to know
where we're at
just two quick questions on page um 87
of build books
um it refers here to the sale of two
investment properties i just want to
clarify that's our and lower esk is that
what you're referring to
threat correct and the other issue there
is the withdrawal of funds from the
maturing terms
is that just what we have in the report
which is roughly six million
that you referred to before about the
loans to icl or that
something beyond that that is just us
managing the cash by withdrawing term
deposits
um rather than borrowing okay thank you
thank you can i move to the
recommendations then please which is we
received quarterly report
um uh we we note that it's already been
received by darren's group
um and that uh the process to improve
performance management with the
organization
uh which is a component of the wider
improvement process um for the 2024
long-term plan
right that
thank you darren i'll put the motion all
those involved please say aye aye those
against
it's carried thank you very much
can we move to the internal audit and
continuous improvement update please
thank you
hey peter welcome
good morning morning councillors i'll
take the report as being read i'd just
like to take the opportunity to
highlight the background sections where
i've
taken the opportunity to um
i like the the benefits and importance
of continuous improvement internal audit
and how it works in with risk management
framework
thank you for taking the questions on
report any questions thank you look
thank you for this but it gives a good
sense particularly of the work going
forward and this is very short and quick
chance to work out actually if you get
these reports particularly ones
that are that are occurring going
forward
are they the sorts of assurance that we
would actually expect bearing in mind
that i'm sure you've worked through a
good process with delights on this i
don't know also i'm sorry i don't want
to also discard the fact that the
continuous improvement
recommendations that
peter's also working on is also just any
questions
this is a sort of a probing question um
does it does it go as far at a higher
level to see that council is compliant
with with
certain acts
legislation or is it at a lower internal
level
sorry what what what which part of the
report are you referring to i'm just
talking about compliance um you know do
we comply with um
there's an article here on uh
are we complying
so i can give us the reference right
let's get back to it
i'm monitoring compliance with policies
yeah what page please
okay
page 89 board box
audio
so i'm just i'm just saying uh you know
from a from a client viewpoint you know
compliance with local government act
waste minimization act different efforts
like that is that does that refer to
that or is that better
that's money for our internal processes
and policies counsellor on
where we'll audit
our
animal welfare facility to ensure we're
abiding by the policies and process the
animal welfare act
at that level that's the capacity and
capability we have in the house right
okay that's been answered thank you
right ross i think you're the question
sir mine's just a comment saying i'm
pleased to see that the tech one
implementation review is completed
yeah and
well it gives some comfort now yeah yeah
thank you through yourself chi i just
wanted to uh reconfirm for uh councillor
pottinger's question in relation to
compliance um
our policies are drafted in respect of
compliance so they cover off the acts
and legislation from that perspective
and our continuous improvement process
is
checking that we are
have that compliance in place as part of
that process
so by checking the policies we're
checking the compliance components we we
do make sure that we are following all
legislation from that perspective as
part of our internal water continuous
improvement process
thanks to that
i've got one comment
peter just just in terms of delight work
um and i'm not going to die on the ditch
in this one i look at the i look at the
nature of the internal work relative to
and now particularly the long-term plan
um
because we're getting
even though we've got to get through an
election that's going to be a big set
piece i know we've got the annual pain
to still get out of the way and i had
wondered in terms of the timing
whether the major infrastructure project
management review which deloitte have
2324 shouldn't be done a year earlier
i'll leave that as a suggestion i'm not
it's not it's not critical i would
probably drop the treasury management
review for the subsequent year would be
my would be my view because it would be
great to have that infrastructure work
done prior to us doing significant
planning well
we shouldn't have done i'm sure before
then um but as we go into the cleaning
round the 23-24
view that i'd suggest but don't i'm not
going to ditch on that one we'll have
the next draft
um internal order plan coming up for the
august rna committee so that'll be the
time to make those changes to you yeah
so look it's a recommendation i've got
it's a suggestion i'm making about
people with you but that's trying to
look at this from a lens of what we need
to have in place of assurance over
to be able to adopt the long campaign
okay
can i move to the uh the rectum in
the recommendations ross i suspect you
want to move this given the second one
firstly we received and that we note
that all the recommendations on tech and
i take it you're going to move this one
with
you're smiling as well which is good
okay do i have a second please
i'll sign that okay let's go um all
those in favor please say aye
those against
it's gary thank you very much
all right we can move to uh
thank you for that peter can we move to
the policy program plan update i'll
think around on your back thank you
so once again i'll um
take the report as read and just note
that we're making good progress through
the necessary bylaw consultations and
reviews
thank you appreciate that
um questions comments for rhiannon or
the single team
yes darren
thanks cheer um look several of these
come up
at uh ppp this afternoon but rhiannon
given that we're coming to the end of a
term are we confident that we'll be able
to get these through in sufficient time
um we've planned carefully around the
electoral cycle
so that we will have a number of these
bylaws complete before and then the
preparation work done so that we can
recommence
the work with the new council
around those later ones like the water
supply thank you
thanks darren
um rian and i was interested in on page
105
eyes always get attracted to
to
red in particular
i noticed asset management down to
park's disposal policy
roughly broadly financial in nature
and probably a wee bit of ground to make
up there
you know for instance things like there
i started keeping our keeping our sort
of
uh hands clean things like our credit
card policy which is all by december 17.
your general assurance that things are
getting picked up will include
those sorts of
policies as well
absolutely yes we're working with um the
finance team around combining some of
those into
a more usable document
and we're just getting through the
annual cycle
bring it now it's just good i'm um i
would i'd love to see that uh and sort
of follow up on darren's point
particularly i feel like i'm
being focused on auditors but it's good
for us to know that we've got those
those up today
uh come come the time to to
make representations to our auditors
which is good what's the difference
between a chief executive version and
the council and finance version of the
delegation register
some come from the council and some come
from them
note the engagement calendar for 2022
and the policy schedule i'll move that
from the chat i have a second to please
thank you darren i appreciate that i'll
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
those against it's carried thank you
yes i thought brianna might have been
trying to escape too quickly
oh this is this is the one that i
thought particularly focused on before
the meeting started seriously
this was a delight to read
because i think it's so important that
even even though it's technically two
years away we're starting to think
seriously
about not only delivery but also risks
so well done on this paper but i'm in
your hands please
um
yes so thank you chair so this paper is
just really intended to show the
progress of the teams across the various
work streams in preparation for the knox
next long-term plan
um we'll note the paper provided by
infometrics which we commissioned a
little earlier than perhaps we normally
would do given the volatility in the
environment at the moment the importance
of planning ahead which we are
continually monitoring in terms of key
financial inputs
um we're also aware of some of the big
strategic issues coming up and doing the
groundwork so that when the new council
is in place we can start working with
them on what they want to do about those
strategic issues
um
[Music]
so
that's probably all i would say in
addition to the report itself
thank you arana it's a very clear report
we have questions or comments for him
yes nobody just a number of them um
on page um
115 116 aboard books we've got a list of
risks there and i just wonder whether we
should also have the risk of the future
of local government
which is in is in that time frame going
forward we don't have that yet um but it
is something that's ahead of us
unlikely that we'll have the status quo
going forward
and just on on
the attached report
um on page 117 seeing leslie's not here
though i can do the the typos because i
like doing those um
um
the group report talks in one of the
pages about 170
um on page 120
uh 70 to 100 a week it doesn't say per
week but it should say that per week
yeah later on report it does say that
that would be correct
um
are you talking about the infometrics
yeah sorry on key points on page 120.
you come down two four six which bullet
bullet points strong
inflation over the next two years
and it says we'll add 70 to 100 to
household
essentials but that's per week
as you go forward in the report it does
say that on page 127 yes correct um
and the other reflection i would make is
two things i have spoken to brad olsen
about the last of the two things
one has a reflection on that that
households will struggle with race so
that's part of the inflationary stuff
it's not just we're not in isolation of
that
the other thing is the issue of slow
tourism recovery and its impact on sot
what he doesn't reflect is there's
actually been some degree of growth and
internal tourism so that's the grey
nomads and running around their
campervans and doing a lot of stuff that
they would normally do overseas
and quite a few reports on this issue
have not recognized there is some pick
up there to talk to operators they'll
tell you that
so just a reflection on that so it's
good it's good to have this as a
baseline isn't it i think but yeah i
don't know what your plans are in terms
of
how we check in on these assumptions
because clearly we'll have to as you
develop the ltp but we've got to start
something those are good points to keep
in mind
um in regard to um
your first issue and i wanted to raise
this uh navi uh you're quite right at
this stage obviously we're planning for
three waters
on our as as the owner and the operator
um in terms of the ltp for 2434 at the
stage
yes so um i would just draw attention to
the first risk on the risk schedule
which is around when the timing of the
information on local government reforms
which relates to all of those
and the approach that we're taking in
terms of trying to look ahead and
respond to what we're doing but
absolutely there is also risk on there
around the how we will deal with the
three borders
reform in terms of timing and around the
financial modeling and how we are
preparing essentially two approaches to
enable us to
respond in whichever direction we need
to
thank you and i'll also note your last
risk as well which i want to not be
whether that was part of it as well
which is reflecting
um through this establishment may
impact and and come in
tim you've got a question sir yes just
um i'm wondering what impact
the
meetings have been having on three
waters
um
the
speech by peter williams and the
pectoral and gore
certainly
impressed on me the
likelihood that
councils all over the country will
change if they don't
face up to
the real feeling of
uh the people in our communities
agree and that's why i think um nobby uh
tim man or surrounding recognizing from
our perspective of having to deliver a
long-term plan
we have to retain the three waters issue
as a as a significant risk
because it's it's still yet to occur um
even though we do have a water services
entity building in the house
so um i think that's a that's a
challenge that we're just we
it's another it's a no no no no i
suppose i'm risking saying that um and
it could still significantly affect the
way the long-term plan gets gets done
which causes this committee's
responsibility which is what are the
risks to it knobby you just wanted to
clarify that what i raised before was
not necessarily in relation to three
waters it was in relation to the the
future of local government so for
arguments say what would happen if we
had amalgamated councils here in a
couple of years time that would
seriously change how we can deliver
things and what we would deliver sorry
look fair point and i i agree with you
and resource management reform comes in
there too yes
can i just respond on that so counselor
the first risk is around the broader
local government reforms
and the way that we are trying to deal
with that is
by addressing the known themes which is
one of the reasons for the focus on
community well-being and some of the
preparations around that work to help
you um with the decision-making in the
new council
and that is the approach that we're
trying to take to get the information
together that will help the councillors
respond to that agenda
when i say mr chuman that
peter williams's speech
he
pointed out on three occasions
that this council
was um
had kept up with it with the maintenance
on its assets and
selling our praises to high heaven
and
i like to
figure out some way of expressing that
um i think that might be for a different
meeting so tim it's not that's not for
us here we're trying to deal with the
area of risk so i suspect there's
another
avenue that you can you can raise that
matter if that's okay with respect
our focus is on this particularly this
table around what are the what are the
challenges to it if there's a response
that is broader dare i say it more
political that's for a different
part of the
we've got a great start um i didn't make
one comment and i risked getting into uh
uh claire's area particularly the
pre-food but i actually think that
diagram would be great for all future
for all candidates clear to understand
what's in front of them if they're
standing for council um and it's a
tremendous diagram because it reflects
two things one actually we're organized
well i'm reno that's what i've got to
put a big upload to but secondly it does
reflect the real challenge of what
councillors individually and
collectively will be engaged in in a
significant way once they once the
elections are declared so i think that's
really superb
brandon i'll be very keen that we
maintain our light touch but but clear
focus around the risks i wonder um as we
go into this whether the fact there
might even be some traffic lights you
could put down the side of the right
hand column there
in terms of highlighting the trend with
those risks are they okay
are they raising more concern very happy
to take them the way they are at the
moment knowing that actually
those risks will change as we go through
the process
there is a more detailed risk schedule
and it would be attached later in the
process craig thank you very much that's
really really helpful can we move to the
uh resolutions please which is that we
receive we have the timeline for
delivery um the assumptions around them
for metrics we have a discussion about
that uh the progress
of the climate change
working group we discussed that but it's
in there and we note the planning
delivery of performance monitoring
we've discussed that but it's in there
as well i'll move from the chair that we
we'd up thank you uh becks i'll put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
aye those against let's carry thanks
random appreciate that
project management office status update
report
thanks michael
hurricane here
i'll take the report as read
one one thing i would like to highlight
which has changed over time is on the
dashboard that has been provided to the
committee
we've correctly and
entitled one of the headings back to
estimate to complete
that is the one that has been
a focus of attention in the past that is
the
looking at the worst case risk
perspective uh from a financial risk of
the those projects
so we we take it um at the stage of the
project as that and look at the
highest level uh risk associated to that
we've had attention on one particular
line in the past and i just wanted to
draw that as a risk assessment at the
time the project does
you will see out to the side we've got
no reds at the moment in relation to our
wrist register which is good uh we are
monitoring some very closely and you'll
see the the two that are in red in
relation to the very variation figure
are both um in their orange or amber
light and those because they are being
very closely monitored and work through
with the project teams about mitigation
measures
to try and bring that back within those
signed off budgets i would say from that
perspective
one of them obviously has gone through
the annual plan process which the
mitigation measure was to look at the
funding in relation to the museum
project as it is listed on here
i'll leave it there and open up for
questions thanks michael um again very
good report do i have questions from
lobby
a number of questions in relation to the
cab building
and the museum so just wanted some
clarification on what progress we were
at to date
so um i asked a question of the finance
team about a week ago a week and a half
ago
about how much money was going to be
spent on this building and then it's
financially and i think the reply i got
was about six hundred thousand
so that there's still quite an awful lot
of money there so i'm on am i right to
assume that the
the remainder of that money which is the
bulk of it will be done in the following
years
uh through soft chair yes that is
correct the
the initial stage is still about the
investigation component and defining
what the
agreed scope is from that within the
project so the project team is meeting
on a regular basis to try and get that
scope defined then we'll obviously go
into design
and then construction follows on from
that so we're
we're quite a way off the construction
component at the moment so you are
correct in that timing thank you and the
other one relates to the museum so just
want to get a handle on where we're at
with the
tisbury
storage facility so at this stage we are
close to getting the
designation changed
um and so when
when will we actually start getting into
some shovel really type stuff on
the physical side of it i think through
yourself chair i think that's better
suited to
pass that question over to my colleague
who is the direct sponsor of that
project so i'll pass it over let's see
kia ora through you the chair i'm sorry
council could you repeat that question
sure just in relation to the story
facility at tisbury
um i think you've clarified recently
both you and caroline have clarified
that um the designation of the land will
be changed shortly
um so do you i mean at this stage do you
have plans for the
drawn up for the storage and and if you
do or don't when can we likely see some
against activity on the site
is this before or after the election
um in terms of the the overall program
we're expecting that
once the decisions passed on the 28th of
june that we'll have a briefing
on where we've progressed
and from that point then we would expect
to see a design
conceptually anyway within
i would say three months from that
period okay
thank you so it's after the election
uh it'll be around
it'd be around that election period yes
um and just one one final
question i guess for you michael is when
we are signing up some of these
of those two pro objects in particular
that have stages to them as we go
through i assume that in the contracts
that we have we will have exit clauses
as well
through yourself chair it's standard
procedure in relation to our contracts
to go through right
yep excellent thank you for that
just running
um look i just want to get some clarity
around the uh cab
um
the extra 10 million in there now
that's look we we did the long term plan
and it was 16 million
and uh we did that we budgeted
everything around that now there's this
10 million sitting there that really
concerns me because
when i
look at
forward to make it all fit
in a budget point of view and things as
we'll be discussing this afternoon are
popping up all over the place that are
that are making the rates increase from
our projected 4 percent
it worries me that's in the back of my
mind like i we talked about stage 2
of streetscape now
i would forego that
knowing
that this is lurking in the background
is it real or is it not real i mean it's
it's just tough to make decisions when
you see something like an extra 10
million there that someone's put in
and you're going and i've been at these
workshops and i'm going oh this is this
is scary
uh through yourself chair um i i would
probably answer that
last point you made it is scary um it is
it is the nature of
capital works in relation to
financial estimates
they do change at the time that you are
doing all of the different scoping this
one is very much in the early stages so
they need to be as cautious as possible
and give give the project team the
best case they can at that time of
estimate so it's not going to be the
best case in relation to a financial
position but it is
turning around saying this is your risk
and that's what the project's job is
project manager's job is to do upfront
and so here's your your risk it is then
about trying to mitigate that risk in
relation to do we want to
change the scope of our projects do we
want to
seek further funding from that
perspective they are two
clear options that are available and we
do that on
pretty much every single project that we
need to do
and
for
strategic projects but also for our
renewals project as well we have to go
through that whole process each time and
at each stage gate
it's part of the
rigor we're bringing to project
management in
icc to make sure that we're doing that
for every single project cab is no
different to any of the others and we'll
bring them back if we need to seek
funding if the project identifies that
later on at that so at this stage there
isn't a design that's been
scoped up or finalized to be able to
give you those numbers
when when does it at some stage trigger
us to reflect on the ltp and and say
right this is we're going to have to you
know like even our significance policy
when does that happen because we're
trying to i mean we're trying to be
prudent
but it's very hard to be prudent when
you've got all these red flags probably
thank you through self-chair that would
be during our planning cycles or you
would be highlighted in a quarterly
report in relation to those
and come back as separate bids from from
that in normal process so there's
definitely those stage gates if it's
that significant it will be at an annual
plan or ltp timing
from this one it is not in that position
at this stage because it has not been
worked through in a design perspective i
would suggest that from a timing
perspective it'll be in that position
throughout the course of the next annual
cycle
i would suggest it'll be in one of the
quarterly performance reports that'll
come up and get clarity at the next
annual plan
thanks
thank you i've got i've got bobby then
darren
um just two added questions to what
rangy's race which are important issues
um from real perspective michael and
clarify i've got this wrong but a new
council could for argument say dive into
the long-term plan
outside those annual planning slash
long-term planning processes
and change the
focus going forward being mindful that
they would probably have to consult with
the public to do so
uh through yourself chair
that i i'd have to say that is possible
to do an amended ltp under the
legislation
um
and it is the prerogative that the new
council to to look at that okay and it
would come with a significant
time frame and cost correct the time is
is tight in relation to that but it is
the audition yeah yep but having said
that we could pause things while we did
consultation
we're not bound to a long-term plan like
rainey's quite rightly said when we get
some eye watering increases coming our
way which are not not necessarily
determined by council they're determined
by the external environment in some in
some cases mr chair i think this council
has been given advice that the long-term
plan is an indication not a commitment
okay and so yes you could thank you very
much and just one final question for
steve
and michael which is part of the report
he talks about the cultural narrative on
stair street and and streetscape as well
and there's also a comment in the report
that there is some degree of struggle
with the local runaka about their
resourcing and ability to help us get
forward on that issue so i just wanted
some guidance that um
that whatever's designed and whenever
it's designed what we're going to have
in both those areas that will come
forward with some costings that it's not
just an expectation that will roll
forward
yeah through you mr chair look
each of those contracts
for works
has a specific line item for cultural
narrative
and the project teams are working
in partnership with the roonaka
on the agreed scope and some of those
especially when stead street
as a briefed previously have
contractual obligations through mb and
kanoa
and
certainly uh we will keep this council
informed to progress okay thank you
thanks chad i think it's worth pointing
out that with the civic admin building
the ltp shows a
budget figure of 16 million and whilst
the potential for that to go out by
another 10 is is being signaled the
decision still has to come back to
council and if council says no the cap
is 16 million then the project has to be
scoped back
thanks darren that's what i assume was
the case so there's still a long way to
go with this one before it's got any
reality
sorry i'll be your final question yeah
instant comment uh
my colleague um i guess what i was
alluding to my previous comments was
while the 16's there with a flag that it
could be more which is an appropriate
flag to have i guess what i was
signaling with the long-term plan
options that we might have available it
might be that we actually don't commit
to that 16 million until we know what
the future of local government is
so that
that's that pausing effect and
reconciling
thank you and that all goes back to iran
is good paper as well the local
government reform is is a real um uh
sort of shadow cast over any of our
long-term clinical stage
that's a great report thank you um
michael i suggest
what i sent some this from the last
quarter is a lot of wrangling with these
projects
uh probably um uh in the last quarter to
get these in line in a way that they
actually are appreciative that we're
focused on the cab and the in the museum
there are obviously out riders not that
they're not being wrangled or under
control but actually they are they are
significant challenges for the council
so i appreciate that
so with that i would like to move to the
recommendation please which is um simply
in this case we received the report um
do i have a move thank you nobody to
have a secondary
thank you rangi appreciate that i'll put
the motion in please always in favor
please say aye
those against
it's carrie thank you very much steve
and mike appreciate that
can we move to the
conflicts of interest
policies please
michael
kelda so this is a report presenting an
updated version of the conflicts
of interest policy to this committee for
consideration and hopefully adoption
i hope it's relatively self-explanatory
so i don't believe i need to spend too
much more time on it and we'll answer
any questions
important yes
yep um just on page one of the reporter
on page
144 of board books
there's a
comment there about perceived
and and i think darren for his guidance
some time ago and from michael as well
that's very subjectively worded i mean
you couldn't even be more subjective if
you wanted to and i know this is a very
difficult area about perceived
perceived conflicts but when it says
perceived occurs when a reasonable
person knowing the facts i don't know
what a reasonable person is
would consider that a conflict of
interest may exist whether it is or is
not the case i mean that's just so
open-ended and so open to i guess debate
amongst members and i'm not sure how you
actually clarify that um
i've seen what's in the legislation
because michael has given me a very good
update and darren giggles good steer at
the last committee on that as well
but i just wonder whether and maybe it's
beyond our escape but maybe
the government or somebody through the
lg uh local government act needs to give
some
clearer definition around that
potentially i don't know just don't too
much interpretation for me
michael have you commented you want to
make on that no for what it's worth i
tend to agree with uh council o'clock on
this but that is the nature of perceived
um
conflicts of interest and unfortunately
the reasonable person
as mr cameron sitting behind me will
well know as a legal test that we all
love in terms of law but is unhelpful to
pretty much everybody else
and it's it's it's one where um
we i would want to argue that we we need
to tr we need to approach knobby in a
spirit of cooperation with one another
if we can be open about the perception
of conflict to then have a
an open discussion as to how that falls
may help that member make that decision
uh because unfortunately as we know
there's only one place which is the
court that can decide what whether
whether the perceived conflict is is one
in reality sure so i i take your point
that's a tough area this is again a
tough policy any other comments for folk
michael just one one
minor suggestion which is under
supplying to invercargill city council i
think it might be useful to say 25 000
inclusive of gst
um always get supplies unfortunately
it reflects the 1968 act i'm afraid that
didn't have gst when it was written but
it has been subsequently determined that
it is inclusive of gst so it's a pretty
small amount these days
right what's that can we move to the
resolution please i think we are in a
position michael to to help you get this
through so it is that we received the
report and the committee adopts the
conflicts of interest policy thank you
nobu do i have a second to please thank
you rangi i'll put the motion then
please all those in favor please say aye
close against
it's carried thank you very much
roddy where are we at in our agenda we
are up to
um
uh the business enhancement program
please michael
thank you through yourself chair so this
is a verbal update in relation to where
we're at with our business enhancement
program so
it's uh
one thing that makes me excited is
trying to make efficiencies and
improve this improve the organisation
for the greater outcome of public
benefit
um and hopefully in the longer term some
financial benefit for the public as well
from that perspective
from our
current state in relation to that and i
apologize it's been quite a
quite a while since we've managed to get
a release of the program to the
committee we are getting very close to
that position
but i wanted to highlight a couple of
things that have been ongoing
from our perspective
in the
background so council and committee have
some reassurance that we we are
continuing to work on our improvement
activity
so we we have had a
project underway to look at our supply
chain and what improvements we can make
in there we did the first phase when we
did our financial project we are now
working through the second phase of that
component
and that is going quite well but
from that perspective that will be
in full project mode as we speak but it
will be in delivery phase probably in
the next about three to six months from
that perspective so
that will be exciting from working with
our suppliers and making some speed
improvements from that perspective
the other component we're about to kick
off is looking at our
internal space and our people and that
is about getting the capability
and
systems and processes in place for our
people to be able to service our public
a lot
easier
that hopefully will come with some uh
well no not hopefully it will come with
some efficiencies in relation to
that to help our customer experience
but those two
core components for us to be able to
deliver on our customer experience we
can't deliver on our improved customer
experience without those two components
being in place they are those building
blocks to achieve that outcome i want to
give i want to give the committee
assurance that we are working in the
background on that it has taken
some time to get to this stage because
taking a stock take
taken a review in relation to what is in
place in relation to our systems our
processes
and the way we are building the program
so we have done review of how we provide
the service internally to
for our systems
and processes and they will be
part of the report that will come back
to the committee in relation to our
wider program
the business enhancement program is
about customer first and about building
a front-end improved customer services
and experience
open to questions thanks michael
appreciate that any questions
it's useful i think it's really like
somewhere as you said i think we once
you've got things mapped out there may
be a paper
which we can react to but that's very
helpful to have that update i'd like to
move from the chair that we receive
michael's level update do i have a
second to please
thank you rangi i'll put the emotional
loads in favor please say hi
thank you very much um the knowledge and
business under public
that i've been advised of so can we
please move to the resolution um which
is to exclude the public for a number of
items that we have in front of us
um uh i'm comfortable they should be
done that was in px so i'll move from
the chair that we we do move into uh
the excellent reason stated thank you
darren is there any discussion on the
motion
being done i'll put it all those in
favor please say hi
those against
it's carried
i'm needing to keep myself going at a
reasonable speed i hope you don't mind
you